Rogers went to the Kali well man saved
together
it on the dog
you
look a lot yes did you retrieve
something from that robot have you seen
a robot with a brain like that before no
but my old Caravan discovered records
about them while we were scavenging
military facilities according to my data
banks it's called the Robo brain it was
considered one of the most
technologically superior robots ever
constructed but the model never reached
full production status just this piece
of junk and John may hold the purpose
impressive technology if my analysis is
correct this is a specialized radar
beacon I suspect until the mechanist was
keeping track of the Robo brain you
destroyed as the next logical step I
need you to install the speaking within
me so we can use it to our advantage
are you sure well there's only a seventy
eight point three percent chance that
I'm correct I'd like to point out that
it's the only lead we have that's too
dangerous perhaps but I'm confident that
reward will outweigh the risk you'll
need to use a robot workbench to ensure
proper installation and my presence will
be required to maintain peak efficiency
I strongly recommend that we remain
together until the radar vegan is
successfully installed you just see the
word may be constantly trying
I'd be happy to help if I can haida a
moment the modification was successful
new hardware has been detected and
software is updating and installation
complete analyzing mechanist hardware
the radar beacon is receiving a strong
encrypted signal but I can't determine
the source do you think the mechanist
knows we're tampering with the beacon
I've already added fail safes to ensure
my location is secure and prevent any
unintended commands the signal may issue
unfortunately one of that will help us
determine the signal source it's a good
start at least absolutely with some
additional assistance I should be able
to decrypt the signal and locate the
mechanist fortunately I'm detecting
another Wilbur brain in the Commonwealth
that's receiving the same signal which
means the one I destroyed isn't the only
Robo brain under mechanist control yes
and we can use this to our advantage the
encryption on the source signal is
complex but not beyond solving if you
can bring me two additional beacons they
should provide the keys and algorithms
that I need to enhance my decryption
routines all right let's do it good
let's get started I'm uploading the
location of the Robo brain to your pet
boy now just be careful these robots
tend to travel in groups so you're
likely to encounter heavy resistance
hey yes here you go ADA one slightly
dented but still functional radar beacon
yes what do you nicely and with any luck
it'll help us trace the mechanist signal